all right guys
bang bang i've got yoga here with me
thank you so much for doing this thank
you for having me you're fresh off the
plane we are ready to rock and roll 100
all right everyone is talking about
defy on bitcoin i tweeted something
everyone comes with a pitchforks they
think i'm an idiot which means they
think you're an idiot too
so let's just start with what the hell
is defy on bitcoin
well you know i mean i think i am
probably you as well i'm most
comfortable in the situation where
everyone thinks we're an idiot because
that probably means we're on to
something
true so look you've got this monetary
tool right this new monetary asset
bitcoin
it's by far the biggest crypto assets
but it's more than that i think if you
look at the entire expense of
any asset in the world right gold
dollars
rubles doesn't matter what you're
looking at bitcoin has the highest
likelihood of all of them
to be the global reserve currency in 10
to 15 years
true so then the question is all right
what is a world where you have this
digital
reserve currency bitcoin look like and
what you want is you want to have a
financial system that is as
transparent and as incorruptible
as the monetary asset itself right we
don't want to just
change money we want to change the ways
we use money and that's what d5 for
bitcoin is and that's why everyone
thinks it's a huge deal because
if it happens and it's happening it
changes
not just money it changes all of finance
and economics
okay i want to go back in history for a
second i'm going to very over
generalized uh version of how we get to
where we are today
you correct me or disagree as we go
bitcoin is created
it's amazing everyone loves it they
start to adopt it that knows about it
and feels that it has value
at some point along that journey people
say i want to do things with it
i want to build on top of it it's hard
to do if not
not possible to do at the time
instead of waiting to figure out how to
do that
or waiting for the development of a
layer two some people went and built
a new platform ethereum which had
composability smart contracts all these
aspects that
uh deliver value to the ethereum
ecosystem
since then there's been more and more
smart contract platforms built but
basically
there was a new way of thinking about
this many of those early people thought
that they would be able to scale
a smart contract platform on a layer one
fast forward to today
i think most people realize wait a
second and the the general consensus
would be
we can't actually scale these on layer
one we're gonna have to scale on layer
two and there's now a lot of work matic
etc that are going in doing this
so if you look at the two ecosystems we
have bitcoin a
truly decentralized digital open
protocol
and you have ethereum that's proof of
work today transitioning to proof of
stake at the layer one
and then they've got kind of layer two
bitcoin's got layer two as well
when you look at those two systems most
people believe that
all of dpi is going to get built on
ethereum
most people have written off that no d5
is going to be built on bitcoin
this is like the ultimate market setup
where
everyone in my opinion i think yours as
well is overvaluing one side of that
equation
and to completely ignoring it not even
just undervaluing just completely
ignoring the other side of the equation
of d phi on bitcoin
right does all of that seem to make
sense is that all pretty accurate you
think
yeah i think i think that makes sense
you know there's this
theory that um blockchains have network
effects
and i don't think they do i don't think
the bitcoin blockchain has a network
effect i don't think the ethereum
blockchain has a network effect i don't
think any blockchain has a network
effect
why because who cares like nobody
says to themselves i really want to use
the bitcoin blockchain
nobody says to themselves i really want
to use well very few people say to
themselves i really want to use the
ethereum blockchain right
what people want is the features that
the technology provides
so we have gotten confused because it's
true
that the bitcoin blockchain has a
network it
has a network but it isn't the network
itself it's not what's capturing
the network value where the network
value is captured
is in the asset now up until now
that wasn't obvious and the reason
wasn't obvious was because everything
was working on layer one
and every time someone wanted to launch
a new technology a new app and knew
anything they basically went and created
a new layer one for it right so
ripple wanted to build i don't know for
banks
they created their own layer one uh
ethereum wanted to create smart
contracts they created
their own layer one tesos wanted to have
a thing where you have governance they
created their own layer one right
everyone was going creating their own
layer one
but um that was a mistake
it was a mistake for two reasons first
of all what we're seeing now is that
layer ones
do not scale you cannot put a huge
amount of functionality
onto a layer one and expect it to scale
and
beyond that that coming back to what i
was saying earlier
where the network effect is not in the
blockchain
it's in the assets so bitcoin is
a powerful network it has a powerful
network effect because it is the network
of people who want to have a store of
value
they want to have access to the reserve
currency of the future
there are other assets which have
powerful network effects tether has a
powerful network effect it's the leading
um a bridge to the fiat world and as a
result it has the deepest liquidity it's
on the most exchanges it has the most
pairs now tether is a perfect example of
what the future looks like tethers
started on bitcoin
on a bitcoin layer called omni
it then migrated to ethereum today the
vast majority of tether
is on tron right tether doesn't care
and in fact bitcoin doesn't care either
when you take your bitcoin
and start using bitcoin on lightning
network you're effectively using
a secondary network when you use bitcoin
on
a sidechain like rootstock you're using
it on a secondary chain
right a totally different network but
you maintain the same network
effect and the same access to the
network effect because it's the asset
which is the network the actual
underlying technology so if we look at
the ethereum ecosystem because
uh they were smart enough to uh not name
the asset and the network the same thing
right
so in the ethereum world you have ether
the asset ethereum the blockchain itself
right the argument you're making is that
ether has the network effect not
ethereum the actual blockchain
okay so it's not entirely true that
there's a zero network effect there's
some degree of network effect
but it's diminishing over time so
the reason ethereum has a network effect
is because
of the composability right so
i create a financial application
you create a dap right your financial
debt
uses mine and mine uses like maker or
whatever
and so it's very convenient for us to be
on the same chain
until you get to 2021 and what happens
in 2021 is suddenly we realize that
there's a huge amount
of use of these chains
they cannot scale and so what starts to
happen
is people start looking at layer two
technologies
um real quick to interrupt you what
ethereum's going through in 2021 is
essentially what bitcoin went through in
2017
right which was so many people were
trying to use the layer one
fees skyrocket you get tons of
mempool just being backed up you can't
actually get transactions through in any
sort of timely fashion
and therefore the bitcoin community said
hey we really got to invest in
scalability layer 2 and
there's this kind of big thing ethereum
now
was trying to scale layer one they now
have experiences
there's obviously uh fee skyrocketing
and a lot of backup on the actual
transactions of the chain because people
are trying to use it right right
but they can't use it because the layer
one doesn't scale and so now they're
being forced to go and pursue
all sorts of different scaling solutions
some will work somewhat whatever right
but that's where really
they're kind of learning their lesson
because they experience the pain now
they go and they try to build layer tips
right so they're both encountering the
same problem because they've both
finally
you know in 2017 bitcoin reached a
degree of scale where it encountered the
problem
now ethereum has reached the degree of
scale where it's encountering a problem
but they're reacting in different ways
okay explain all right so what happened
to bitcoin
is bitcoin went through a civil war and
what it decided to do
and i think this is an extremely
temporary thing but it changed the
narrative for a while
what bitcoin basically decided to do was
reject
um computationally intense use cases
not increase the the the the the size of
blocks and make sure
that the holy of holies right the fact
that
the chain would remain the same that it
would always be reliable and that the
store of value would always be based on
a
highly reliable system would not be
touched high security
high decentralization not so worried
about layer 1 scalability or
what's the latest innovation bells and
whistles etc just pure
security and decentralization was a
direct trade-off with everything else
but that was an intentional trade-off
that's right okay ethereum is making a
different trade-off okay
they both also going to end up in a
fairly similar place what ethereum is
doing
is ethereum is fragmenting so
um you've got arbitrum which is a new
layer one
launched uh two days ago you've got
matic have launched
a side chain which doesn't even use
ethereum um
as its base currency you've got x-die
which also uses a proof-of-stake
consensus mechanism
not ethereum's consensus mechanism and
then you have all of the
other evm chains like binance smart
chain
right all of them are absorbing
huge amounts of um
[Music]
users and flow from ethereum
and what we're seeing is more and more
depths are migrating to one or more of
these different chains and so the
composability that provided this network
effect
it's breaking it's breaking which means
that it wasn't a true network effect
i think it was a temporary network
effect right you can have a temporary
network effect
but you can have dependence without
having a true network effect
uh right so you each depend on each
other and there is some
value or efficiency that is gained from
that but ultimately
a true network effect would be nearly
impossible to break
if it had actually taken hold well i
think that's interesting right so
if you think about like the difference
between say facebook and ethereum right
facebook never encountered this problem
because it's not like when facebook
reached 10 million users
its servers stopped working so it has
a true network effect and i think
ethereum did have a true network effect
it's just that that network effect
itself could not scale
okay interesting now that network effect
is not going to disappear entirely i
don't think ethereum is going to
disappear i think
ether right eth is continue is going to
continue to have
value in the future right i agree but
it's but the trajectory is
not what people are anticipating right
now what people should be paying
attention to is that there has been a
complete
change in the trajectory of where
ethereum is going
and that's going to change it's going to
impact everything it's going to impact
how the wallets operate it's going to
impact
um how users interact it's going to
inter every
like explorer is going to now need to be
a multi-chain explorer we
are entering a multi-chain world
and that is part of the reason why
going back to the earlier story of what
happened to bitcoin
bitcoin is waking up and coming back
into this game
i want to stay on the ethereum thread
for a second yeah i think it's really
important for people to understand this
ethereum has from the beginning
pursued a narrative around technological
superiority in specific use cases or
specific functionality
so smart contracts composability all
this stuff
what we're now seeing is people have
taken
what i would consider uh a pretty
revolutionary
technological change that ethereum
originally started with
and the evolutionary iterations on that
are showing to be more technologically
superior so faster block times
better throughput lower cost fees all
this stuff
now there are trade-offs right so for
example nft is on
ethereum all of a sudden dapper labs
comes around it says hey
we can't do it here we need a specific
chain built for this they build flow
right you see matic say well is it a
layer two is it a side chain forget
nomenclature for a second
just it doesn't work here we're going to
build somewhat on top of
or kind of leveraging some of the
ethereum actual uh technology but we're
not gonna use ether as that asset as you
described right
you then start to see binance smart
chain trade-off okay
faster block time way more efficient
much lower fees
two times the transaction volume right
almost immediately
and it's very hard to argue that
developers aren't moving to go use this
stuff but it's more centralized
right and so every single one of these
decisions
is a technical trade-off you're trying
to accomplish
x but you're giving up or getting a
worse version of why
who wins is almost irrelevant to the
structural change that you're
identifying which is
there is an all-out war on the smart
contract platform side
of who can build the most
technologically superior system
yeah that is a very different
conversation than the bitcoin system
right bitcoin simply just says we're
gonna be the most decentralized we're
gonna be most secure
period yeah we're not gonna compete on
throughput on layer one we're not gonna
compete on fees all that other stuff is
the trade-off right we're going to give
up all that we're going to say we're not
good at that stuff
but we are the most decentralized we are
the most secure these other
platforms chain side chains etc
they're all saying we're going to give
up on the decentralization not fully but
we're going to compromise
some of the decentralization or some of
this well they don't say that some of
them
would claim that they're not making that
trade-off okay but i
i disagree so i i don't think we've
actually seen
this is the incredible thing about
bitcoin right it was such a fundamental
shift paradigmatically in technology we
actually haven't seen a true
innovation since it right we've seen
different trade-offs we've seen
different considerations you know
ethereum doesn't have nodes
which anyone can run in the same way
that anyone can run a bitcoin node
all right proof-of-stake systems do not
have the same kind
of physical assurances around
you know decentralization and security
that proof-of-work systems have
they have maybe other properties but we
haven't seen sort of a
zero trade-off
improvement right cars have clearly
gotten better over the last 50 years
right like they're in every way
no blockchain has gotten better in every
way over the last 10 years
the thing that i think when i talk about
this to people who aren't super deep in
the weeds like you or i are as i simply
say
bitcoiners are pursuing decentralization
at layer one
over everything else and the rest of
folks are pursuing
something else over pure
decentralization yeah
that doesn't mean either one's good or
bad it doesn't mean that one wins and
the other loses or a zero sum game
it just means that they're fundamentally
optimizing for something completely
different
what becomes interesting for our
conversation today is if you are going
to then get scalability at the layer two
what happens is well what occurs
if we both have the same functionality
on layer two
but i'm tied into a more secure chain
and actually at the same through put the
same fee uh schedule etc at layer two as
you do
then why would i use your layer one tied
in if it's less secure
less decentralized et cetera if i can do
the exact same thing with the same
functionality on top of bitcoin
right and i think this goes to the very
heart of what many people misunderstand
about what's going on
with crypto right i don't think
that it is a new computer technology
right bitcoin is a new asset
um and the and it and it uses technology
in order to generate
that asset but it's not competing on
features
it's competing to be the best money out
there
and so when you have projects that are
competing on features
you just need to look at what technology
companies look like right every 10 years
you have a different
new leader right but money doesn't work
that way and if it
were to work that way it would stop
being money
so that's why it's imperative that
bitcoin not
try to compete in features because they
would be misunderstanding what the game
is then
now so that brings us to where we are
now right so now we've got this world
where you've got a huge amount of
features that have been built
ethereum and the ethereum community the
ethereum developers
have funded and built out phenomenal
technologies
right they're not new blockchain
technologies they're phenomenal
cryptographic technologies
they're phenomenal decentralized
application technologies
but anyone can use them and that is
really one of the
incredible gifts of what ethereum has
provided to the world
and beyond that because of the
fracturing
of ethereum not only that but the entire
ecosystem is
reconfiguring itself to be a
chain agnostic and then in the middle of
that
the very center of gravity of this
entire
ecosystem is bitcoin and the bitcoin
chain
before you go there is it fair claim to
say
that the inevitable end game when you
get fracturing of smart contract
platforms
and you get a multi-chain world that
there's a constant pursuit
of the highest throughput lowest fees
kind of most efficient blockchains and
therefore it may take
years and years and years but you
incrementally continue to get more and
more centralization because it brings
more efficiency and so therefore you end
up back with a centralized system
i'm very scared that that's a possible
trajectory
you're scared that it is possible yes
well like you think it is likely
and that is scary to you very yeah like
the whole reason i'm in this
is because i want to avoid that outcome
so i agree
that that is already writing on the wall
with the way this is going doesn't mean
that we have to go down that path
it could be reversed it could change but
that is where this
ends up as people do it a perfect
example is ethereum and binance smart
chain
if i want faster throughput i want
faster block times if i want lower fees
what do i do
i just bring more centralization leads
to more efficiency
with that said and this is a key piece
to it
is it then brings to the forefront is it
more important to have the efficiency on
the technological front
and to have the throughput and the low
fees or is it more important have the
decentralization
and this is ultimately when you pit the
smart contract platforms versus bitcoin
right as just the comparison this is
where you see the difference right
and so explain now what has changed in
the
bitcoin ecosystem that is now empowering
smart contracts defy on bitcoin all the
things that a decade ago everyone
thought wasn't possible
now seems to be being built and so
what's changed there it's really
interesting that you say a decade ago
right because if you think about it
a decade ago the conversation in bitcoin
was
any technological advance that could
benefit
bitcoin will simply be adopted by
bitcoin and in 2014
a paper was written which described this
thing called
side chains and side chains basically
was a description of exactly how this
was going to happen
what a side chain is is it's a chain
remember i said
the network effect isn't in the chain
it's in the asset it's a chain
which shares the security
of bitcoin and actually there is an
additional network effect which is
proof of work right so bitcoin has by
far the biggest
by far by far the most um hashing power
securing strongest computer network in
the world that is a network effect right
so if you can piggyback
on bitcoin proof of work and on the
bitcoin asset
but have a separate chain which can have
its own rules
its own features then you can
effectively expand
the capabilities of bitcoin to do
anything
one of the things that i want to make
sure people understand and it's not
super technical but i think it's an
important point
is in a block of transactions
approximately every 10 minutes uh there
is a certain number of transactions that
fit into that block
one of the big debates previously was
should we increase the size of the block
so more transactions can go in or should
we keep it the same we kept it the same
but what is important to understand is
if you almost think about it as a
an excel file right just for easy kind
of visualization
and each cell on the row or on the
column down
was a different transaction inside of
that
one single transaction or input into the
ledger
can actually represent hundreds
thousands
millions of other transactions that are
happening on a layer two or on a side
chain
that's right and so even though the
block size
does not change what ends up happening
is the scalability comes from being able
to do all these transactions on the
layer two on the side chain
and then simply writing into a single
block
one transaction right and so what
ultimately we're talking about here is
you get the security and the
decentralization of bitcoins layer one
but you're able to now exponentially
increase the amount of transactions and
economic value that gets put into a per
block
basis which ultimately could swallow
the entire financial system if we wanted
it to without having to
change block sizes or kind of the the
core
structure of that bitcoin blockchain
that's right correct yeah
okay so we actually already see this
happening and we see this happening in
on ethereum uh with technology which has
been developed called
rollups and we see it happening on
bitcoin with technology that's called
lightning network
okay both of them yeah describe ethereum
roll-ups all right so what happens in a
rollup
is and there's a number of ways of
constructing roll-up but so i'll just
talk about this on a high-level
conception but basically what happens in
a roll-up
is you have the base chain l1 layer one
and you know you can't stuff everything
into it and so what you do is you take
the computation um four transactions
and you move them to a separate chain
and now you do all of you and and and
you
you can basically treat this chain very
badly right you can have it be pretty
centralized you can have it be high
throughput you can
give up most of the assurances that you
would want
and you don't care and the reason you
don't care is because
you have this high throughput on the on
the layer 2 on the roll-up
but for it to be approved right for any
transaction to be approved
that it needs to be aggregated with a
whole bunch of other transactions
and then introduced as a confirmed
transaction on later on
and that means that the security is
coming from layer one
but the scalability is coming from layer
two right so you separate those two
things and so you get
the same l1 security but you get also
l2 scalability so
um bitcoin basically does something the
exact same thing with lightning network
right and uses a different way of of
approaching this um but basically both
of them are attempting to do the same
thing
and now we have um bitcoin sidechain
technology which is allowing you to
basically combine the best of both
worlds
so you can take smart contracts
you can take scalability and you can
take bitcoin security
and put them all together into the
tastiest you know decentralized pie you
could possibly make
explain the sovereign platform and kind
of how it technically works
where the security comes from how does
the scalability where the transactions
come from etc
right so bitcoin is built
on a um
bitcoin site and sorry sovereign is
built on a bitcoin sidechain technology
called rootstock and what rootstock does
is
it merge mines a chain
so that you know bitcoin miners they
um basically discover a new block on
average every 10 minutes
but to do that they create huge numbers
of hashes which don't discover a block
so what you do with merge mining is you
say all right
we're going to allow you in that process
to discover blocks on this chain as well
with some of the hashes that weren't
discovering bitcoin blocks so you're
doing the same thing you're getting the
same uh
security you don't need to bootstrap an
entirely new proof of work system
you just basically piggyback on that
security that bitcoin already has
so you have a sidechain you can move
your bitcoin to the sidechain because
it's the base asset on that side chain
and and that is what the rootstock
technology does right
rootstock does an additional thing
rootstock also is evm compatible so
what's evm compatible
it's the same technology that ethereum
uses
for generating smart contracts also
works
on rootstock right so if you think about
what rootstock provides
it's all the functionality of ethereum
uh merged with bitcoin as the base asset
so you don't need
a new token and the security of bitcoin
when you use rootstock you said
bitcoin is the core asset uh or kind of
the the the negative
the native asset to root stock but you
get the functionality of
ethereum right on a very simplistic way
to use ethereum you need ether to pay
gas fees do you also use
ether in this side chain no so use
bitcoin to pay
gas fees right so when you are
interacting with a smart contract you
need to
pay for that interaction basically it's
a transaction fee
and you pay this in bitcoin and so
there's a parsimony here right because
the vast majority of um
crypto asset value is in bitcoin
it's inconvenient to have to have
a new asset every time you want to
transact
and so when you're making transactions
with bitcoin one of the things that
sovereign and rootstock provides is the
ability to just pay the gas fees in
bitcoin itself
and what's cool about it is that where
does that bitcoin go it goes to the
bitcoin miners so it actually expands
not just the capabilities of bitcoin
but the security assurances of bitcoin
as well
when somebody uses the sovereign
platform what can they do
so sovereign huh someone started out as
like a
an idea just about a year ago and has
drawn so much attention and so many
developers
uh or have started working on it that in
the last year
it has become by far the most
feature-rich
d5 platform anywhere in the world it's
got
bitcoin back stable coins so you can now
create dollars without
you can basically compete with the fed
right you've got bitcoin you can
issue dollars um which are not issued by
the fed and are
more secure than dollars in the bank
right it's got
lending and borrowing so you can lend
your record and earn yield in it
and some new features are going to be
coming out that i know some people are
working on which is probably going to
make it the number one place to earn
yield in bitcoin anywhere in the world
you can also borrow bitcoin so you can
go long bitcoin and one of the ways that
you can
do this is within another feature which
is a margin trading so you can
take long or short positions you can
also
um spot trade so you can trade between
usd sable coins bitcoin
ethereum and bitcoin um and
that's where it is now so that's
decentralized lending
decentralized borrowing decentralized
exchange
right all the um in the if we compare it
to
the smart contract platforms each one of
those
exists right and some of them take like
a unit swap is actually very very
popular
right but it is
unit swap is a decentralized exchange it
doesn't have
decentralized borrowing lending all that
other stuff right there's another
uh you know um decentralized application
or decentralized financial application
that has decentralized lending
decentralized borrowing right all the
way through
so when you look at the ecosystem in
general there is
all of this functionality you just have
to swap in and out of either different
assets or go to different platforms all
that kind of stuff that's right
here and that made sense in a world of
composability right yes yeah
here you have a single platform
that uses the same base asset where all
of it
is on that one platform decentralized
exchanges lending borrowing etc
when you think about this
if you continue to be successful
what would the argument be for people to
use the other platforms would they be
more efficient lower cost to more
decentralized
or actually would everyone just stay and
use
the most secure chain with the base
asset the largest base asset
and then just do all the decentralized
lending you know borrowing exchanging et
cetera
all on that one platform the reason i
got excited about suffering is because
i think that there's very strong chance
that it is basically the financial
protocol of the future like the
financial operating system of the future
um i don't know that we need more than
one reserve currency
i don't know that we need more than one
financial operating system
but what i do know is that if we were to
have both of these things
there's a lot it makes a lot of sense
that they would be linked together right
so you know i i
when i was first introduced to sovereign
i was excited because
i wanted to earn yield on my bitcoin i
um never want to use centralized
exchanges
but what's become more apparent to me
over time
as the project has grown and sort of as
a result sort of it's
become more clear how big of a thing
this is
is that everything could be replaced
uh the banks could be replaced the hedge
funds could be
replaced the the the payments companies
could be replaced
by what is effectively a open
transparent and incorruptable
financial operating system uh which is
as
borderless um and as uncensorable um as
uh as crypto will allow um
and that it
we i don't think sovereign itself is
going to
be everything right um already we're
seeing protocols that are building
around the sovereign ecosystem
but sovereign as a platform the reason i
say os
is think about like your your your mac
right your mac provides you with the
basic functions of an operating system
right you can boot up the computer
you can um you know
install software but in addition to that
it also offers you some of the basic
key applications it gives you a browser
it gives you a word processor right
but a lot of people build for that
ecosystem
and and um and i think it makes sense
for sort of like the application layer
of bitcoin to be the same thing
you have the basic financial primitives
things like borrowing
lending and core derivatives that are
provided by the core sovereign protocol
and then a huge amount of innovation
that you can think of like
specific verticals which are provided by
other
applications
when you think through the comparisons
here between the various systems
i've always used the framework of
bitcoin
is a decentralized digital currency
almost all of the infrastructure around
bitcoin has been centralized up until
recently
right that's right centralized exchanges
lending all this kind of stuff
that's about 50 of the way there right
decentralized digital money good
centralized exchanges and and
infrastructure that's not exactly the
promise of a fully decentralized system
but
one best we had two allowed people to do
what they needed to do but they there
was counterparty risk
in the ethereum ecosystem and other
smart contract
platforms the assets are not
decentralized
but the infrastructure is decentralized
right
and when you especially look at things
like sound money and all this stuff
right you get into like a very weird
world where it's obviously different
than bitcoin but the infrastructure is
decentralized
and i've always thought that if you take
the decentralized digital money of
bitcoin
and you take the decentralized
infrastructure that is on these other
smart contract platforms you put them
together you vertically integrate them
yeah winner like that is the home run
winner
what people have debated for a while now
is does that mean you take bitcoin and
you bring it into the smart contract
ecosystems
so wrapped bitcoin and other things like
it right and there's to varying degrees
of success people have tried to do this
or does that mean you bring the
decentralized infrastructure
to bitcoin right historically up until
you know i don't know last two years or
so people just thought you couldn't
build the decentralized infrastructure
type of bitcoin that's right
but now with rootstock and a couple of
other variations of uh
side chains or second layers it's
possible but it's not like possible it's
actually
happening and people are starting to go
and do this yeah and there's hundreds of
millions of dollars if not billions of
dollars of total value locked
in these systems and so the question
then becomes
if the entire premise for the smart
contract platforms was to
get off of the bitcoin layer one because
you needed composability smart contract
functionality
and you needed higher throughput and
lower fees
but now you have smart contract
functionality composability higher
throughput and lower fees
on the bitcoin system what happens to
the rest of
the systems or is it
they still coexist and they still have
some value but ultimately the majority
of the value accrues to the
base asset or the native asset uh or
kind of native reserve currency of the
internet is bitcoin and the vertically
integrated decentralized infrastructure
or is it actually no it's all just
interoperable and so i'm gonna go from
bitcoin to
ether to name your next asset i'm gonna
use all sorts of different decentralized
infrastructure and it's like a full
multi-chain world
where i actually don't care what the
layer one is because i'm just seeking
highest yield most throughput lowest
fees
look i there's
there's so many people who have so many
tokens that they
really love that i don't want to break
their hearts
but the fact of the matter is that the
reason
people call these things altcoins or
[ __ ] coins is because
for the most part look
satoshi invented bitcoin
he hasn't touched one of his bitcoin but
he
created new better money
and then other people looked at this and
they were like wait
i can just make money i want to do that
like i don't want to have a nine-to-five
job i just want to go
fork bitcoin and then say i have a new
coin and then i go to a conference and i
say hey
did you hear about my new money oh
you've got a new money too well why
don't we exchange some of your money for
my money and then you know
like just skip the middleman of work and
go straight to making the money right
but they needed to be able to justify
that somehow so to justify it they
needed to say well look there's all of
these things that bitcoin can't do
and uh we're gonna make a coin that can
do these things that bitcoin can't do
and so they went and they created xrp
and litecoin and you know a whole coin
market capitalist of 2000 different
coins
um and yeah i think probably most of
them are totally useless
now some of them will continue to retain
value because they will find use
for example i think ethereum is never
going to go away i think it has
i agree with that it has created a huge
amount of value
and um it is the king of utility coins
right but
i don't but like i was saying i think
the trajectory that people are expecting
is not the trajectory they're going to
get
a lot of other things are pretty much
going to disappear like shibuynu
you know no one's going to be talking
about it in a year right
and some of them will just take longer
and most of them aren't going to go to
zero in my opinion i don't know about
you i mean some they're all going to
remain
somewhere some kind of weird collectible
from a very very strange time when the
world went insane because everyone
thought they could make their own
currency
and other people were willing to buy it
right
but at the end of the day we do have
network effects
money is the mother of all network
effects that has ever existed
finance and liquidity are massive
network effects
and they have a center of gravity and
that center of gravity right now and
probably and this is why i say the most
likely asset of all the assets you look
at the world of today
is probably bitcoin oh it's inevitable
at this point
i don't think it's inevitable i don't
think anything's inevitable i don't
think we
get to be that um
complacent i i agree
in the sense of nothing is actually
guaranteed but i think that from barring
some
external catastrophic event the
trajectory of the asset
in comparison to all of the legacy
currencies that
also have a potential to rise to global
reserve status
it's i mean it's like not even in the
same realm of possibility so
i i have a very contrarian view in sort
of bitcoin land around this
okay my contrarian view is that we're
not nearly
at that level of certainty okay why
um look at the internet all right the
internet
was going to be freedom for everyone it
was going to be free information
for everyone it was going to mean that
no on the internet nobody knows you're a
dog
right and for its first years it was
this ideal place
that you could go you could have civil
conversations with anyone you could be
you know
it was totally up to everyone it was
choose your own adventure for the entire
world
and what it ended up and what ended up
happening was it ended up centralizing
around the fangs right
google facebook etc
um and that's because the incentive
structure wasn't
right and because people got greedy
ethereum i think um
has can be extremely successful
and i don't think that we should
discount like an option of the flipping
happening
and the reason is that ethereum one of
the things it's about to do is move to
proof of stake now in a proof of stake
system
it's like the the short term
seems so great right you just you've got
this coin and
and you you you you lock it up and you
get more coins right imagine you could
take bitcoin and lock it up and just get
more bitcoin
right so people look at like bitcoin and
so
oh it's very it's like puritan and it's
solid and it's conservative and it
you know but ethereum i can get more
ethereum right
and so on a retail level you could see
people shifting to ethereum
and on the institutional level you could
see people looking at this and saying
this is something i can manipulate and
therefore i'm going to encourage it
because i can end up like you know a
baron of proof of stake
and so i don't want the exchanges be the
barons of proof of stuff exactly
what makes more sense for binance and
for you know coinbase and kraken who
have
who are going to become like coinbase is
a publicly traded company now right
and it's going to have the pressures of
a publicly traded company right and they
they they they can make a lot of money
by getting a lot of people to
give them their ethereum and stake and
then they can tell people listen
if you convert your bitcoin to ethereum
you can make even more money because
coinbase can make even more
money that way right so i don't think
there's an inevitability here
i think it's really really up to us
that's why i think the work that you're
doing is so important it's why the work
that i do is important to me and why i
think everyone who is in this space
needs to be paying attention because
there is
nothing inevitable in my mind about how
this i think i think it's the most
likely
but we have to be extremely careful and
i also think that's why define for
bitcoin is so important because even if
bitcoin
wins as the monetary asset you could
still see all of the financial rails
totally co-opted more regulation the
large
organization
out there but you can't trust anyone
that's the whole point of
all of this right don't trust
so um yeah i know there was a bit of a
tangent but when
you talked earlier you said there is uh
altcoins [ __ ] coins etc
i think a lot of people struggle to
understand the difference between
what i think you would categorize as
bitcoin altcoins
and then tokens right yeah you guys have
sov which is a token
explain maybe first what sov's
role or responsibility is within the
sovereign system
and then describe the difference between
a token and altcoin and bitcoin in your
opinion
maybe i'll do that in the reverse order
okay so i think
pretty much every single bitcoiner knows
that tether
even though it's money right is not
competing with bitcoin
and why do they know that because they
because tether isn't trying to be sound
money
right uh it has no argument
that it's our money it's literally like
a a somewhat risky version of the dollar
right but it has
extreme utility it can be used for
various things
um so that's the difference between um
a coin as i see it right bitcoin is a
coin
which is effectively trying to be a
reserve currency a store of value
as well as a
medium of exchange right and a medium of
account right you get all three of those
you got the holy trinity
ted is not trying to do that now that's
the difference between a coin
and a token now you can have other types
of tokens there's
nfts non-fungible tokens non-functional
tokens are clearly not trying to be
money no
maybe they are useful maybe they aren't
but you know they're definitely not
trying to be
a competitor to bitcoin so bitcoin is a
cryptocurrency meaning it's
decentralized
it's sound money has very specific
properties that's right
and uh as of right now it is the leading
cryptocurrency
that's right and you're making a
difference between a cryptocurrency
having to be decentralized and having to
be
sound money tether while acting as a
currency it's more of like this like
digital currency almost
to some degree where it is simply uh
used for store value medium of exchange
but it's not decentralized it's not
sound money right and on the other hand
is it trying to go for something else
it's a trade-off right but die
for example which is a different stable
coin i think actually is pretty
decentralized
but it's also a token right and in fact
there is a system with two tokens one
which is die which is like the stable
coin and one which is mkr
which is kind of like a futuristic
version of
equity of shares right because the
the maker dao system earns fees and it
pays those fees out
effectively indirectly but it pays those
fees out um
to the mkr holders right
now if you think about a world right
which goes through
hyper bitcoinization right bitcoin is
the central monetary
asset but you have like this entire
decentralized financial system that's
built around it
you're going to want tokens to represent
all of the different financial assets
uh commodities like gold equities
futuristic equities like mkr
the ability to buy and sell property
everything right
and we're going to discover all kinds of
new ways
of interacting and constructing these
things because not only do we have
programmable
money we have programmable finance so
this brings me to sov right so what is
smv
sov is the um the risk and coordination
token
of sovereign it's kind of like a
um you know if if if
uh a monkey is
um equity uh and then then a human being
would be
you know whatever comes after equity
right so it's kind of like the human
being it's the next level i think of
where equity could go if it becomes
programmatic so it's not equity
but it it it provides some of the
functions and many
functions that equity doesn't provide
for the sovereign protocol
so um the sovereign protocol
needs to be able to evolve rapidly much
more rapidly than bitcoin
why because it's not trying to be money
never changing like a like a
law of nature it's trying to be financed
which is highly dynamic and introduces
all kinds of risks
so those risks need to be managed
features need to be developed
and so you need an ability to coordinate
around how to evolve the system that's
one way
that sov is used and that and and and it
does that by creating incentives for
people to think
very very long term so basically what
you do is you take your sov you lock it
up
and you earn all of the fees that the
that the um protocol generates with the
exception of the fees that go to the
bitcoin miners
um they and they get distributed
on the basis of how long you you've
locked up right so the longer you're
locking up the more you
you will earn so i and a whole bunch of
folks that i brought together along with
uh folks who had approached you we built
the syndicate
we bought uh nine million dollars in
change of these sov tokens
and what we are doing is we basically
come into the system
and we say in exchange for the capital
that we've given uh to the project uh
we're gonna leave
these tokens here and essentially we get
if let's say i own one percent of the
tokens which i don't but let's just say
i did
uh i would get one percent of all the
fees you make a hundred dollars in fees
i get one percent of the hundred dollars
in a generalized manner and that
continues to happen
no okay because
because um this is one of the cool ways
in which it's so much better than equity
because it's programmable right
so first of all just by passively
if you just passively hold a tesla share
or you know let's talk about a company
that provides a dividend will march
right
you just passively hold a walmart share
you get money
right if you just passively hold sov you
don't
uh uh you you you need to actively
participate in the system
right so it's sort of like an access
pass into participating and having
influence
over the system and then
um you signal to the system i'm going to
think about the system long term by
locking yourself up for a longer period
of time and you and then you
you you get a better a greater earn out
right
and and this is just one aspect of of
what you do with sov but
it helps demonstrate how this is
different
and i think very very exciting because
what it actually means
is that we now have these financial
asset clauses which are not
cryptocurrencies
but they're also global they're also
borderless and most importantly
they're not protected or they don't rely
on a court system of a particular
country of delaware or
london they rely for their security
on bitcoin miners and cryptographic
property assurances are so much better
than legal property assurances
there's another key difference between
sov and sort of like an altcoin
you never need to use it as a user
to use software so you can go into
someone be totally unaware of sov
so long as you have bitcoin you can pay
transaction fees uh you know lend earn
yield do everything you want
in the same way that you can drive a
tesla car right without
ever knowing about tesla or you can rent
a house without ever knowing about
mortgages right
these are two totally different things
and i think the
recognition the realization that you
don't need to build everything on layer
one also frees you up
to say all right now everything needs to
be a coin
when somebody does this and they're
holding those smv tokens and they've
locked them up right and they're earning
a percentage of
the fees
what is the incentive for
[Music]
them from a participation standpoint
right
is it voting on new features
is it looking at proposals describe
when you talk about active participation
what exactly does that mean yeah
so the um plutocracy which is what the
sovereign governance system is called
is not fully developed and is
continuing to evolve um it has a very
very high level of participation there's
over four and a half thousand
people who have locked up sov and
there's over 60 percent participation
in almost every single vote of which
there are several a month
right i i saw this firsthand so just
pause for a second uh when i wanted to
make the investment
i wrote up with help from others
a investment proposal it's pretty
lengthy
cut you know pages yeah i then put it
forward
into this bittocracy uh system
how many people on the discord 20 000
people or something whatever the number
is some big number
they all have a lot of opinions as they
should they care about the system
there's tons of feedback flying around
questions all this kind of stuff
at one point we scheduled a call
uh i'd never done a phone call on
discord before
mass chaos uh i was like 900 people i
think on a saturday morning got on this
call and now i'm on the call and they're
asking questions everything from
super sophisticated to frankly just hey
you know
thanks so much for your interest and you
know uh it's gonna be cool to work
together and then it went to a vote
and it passed without 99 or whatever
that the percentage of approval was
and only then was there actually an
investment made
right that is a 180 degree difference in
me calling up a founder saying hey i
like your business
i want to invest what are the terms okay
i'm in let me assign a wire
right and only the ceo or the ceo and
the board having the decision over the
entire company
that kind of feels like the future think
about it from the perspective of a
sovereign user
right you don't want to be involved in
any of this but you want to use
sovereignty
but you know that there's four and a
half
thousand extremely rapidly active people
who are examining everything all the
time debating it
you know like like the craziest like
it's governance by
you know a deeply incentivized reddit
subreddit like the kind of people on
wall street bets who discover like this
these crazy investments that no one else
would find this is what the sovereign
community is
except that it knows how to weight
people towards not being
extremely short-term minded but being
long-term minded
it's a huge innovation
in social scalability right like the
ability to have so many people who
basically have your back
i think is phenomenal and you don't need
to know any of them they don't know each
other either
so to me that is
you know when people i you know i was
earlier talking about bitcoin as being a
monetary revolution
but money itself is a is a
social scalability consensus tool right
like there are other very very big
social consensus tools that have been
invented over the course of history
religion for example right like the
catholic phase has
over a billion adherents right but
money has over 7 billion adherents
there's basically no one who isn't an
adherent of money it's the most
powerful social network that's ever
invented that was ever
ever invented and now using
the tools that were invented to create
that degree of scalability for a new
type of digital money
we're also able to start creating new
ways of thinking about
what is like do we even need
corporations anymore
right i don't think we do the reason the
corporation was invented was because
there needed to be a way of
providing monetary incentives for a
large number of people to come together
around a project like
you know farming in
louisiana or building a bridge right
but now we have dowels and i think
as bitcoiners one of the things that i
don't like about a lot of
sort of twitter bitcoin is that there's
a very strong streak of
of almost self-imposed ignorance
they're not interested in anything
that's happening outside of the bitcoin
ecosystem
and i get why right like [ __ ] coins are
[ __ ] annoying
i don't know if i'm allowed to say that
but but
um but there is a lot of well-meaning
people
very very intelligent developers who are
building really really cool stuff
and one of the reasons it's happening
outside of bitcoin is because there are
tokens which aren't currencies but are
being used to incentivize all kinds of
other activities
and so one of the things that sovereign
has done which i think is really cool
is it said look let's think about this
from first principles
we want to use bitcoin security we
expect the financial will to be built
around
the reserve asset which is going to be
bitcoin and we also want to be able to
incentivize the growth of a community
and fund the development so among other
things
that's also a good reason to have a
token and
as a result um sovereign is growing at a
phenomenal pace right just in terms of
the amount of developer like this
i was going to ask you explain some of
the numbers behind the growth so far i
mean there's about as
many core developers in sovereign as
there are on bitcoin
core right now already there's
um over a billion dollars in value that
is being managed by this open system
there's um four and a half thousand
people who are actively participating in
this
new sort of decentralized governance
system there's
the most feature-rich d5 platform
anywhere in the world
and all of this has happened over the
course of the last year
right something
really phenomenal is happening it's i
haven't
seen this level of excitement i've only
seen this level of excitement twice
before
when bitcoin was launched right or at
least when i started to become aware of
booker and which was when like the first
early adopters started becoming aware
and when ethereum was launched and
um yeah i i i think
the crazy thing about sovereign the sov
token for example
isn't traded anywhere yet it's not
traded on exchanges it's not traded on
unity swap
it's um you know it trades purely on the
server and protocol
it has days where it exceeds 50 million
dollars in transactional volume
right that's crazy
and it's about to go on to unisoft it's
about to go into all of these exchanges
you know i that what is about to happen
i think it's going to be um it's going
to be
probably the biggest story
in the coming years of of crypto i'm
betting on it
i continue to say it the most mispriced
opportunity in all of the crypto
industry
is defy on bitcoin yeah i agree it
doesn't mean that it's winner take all
doesn't mean it's a zero-sum game
it just means that if you put defy on
bitcoin compared to let's say d5 and
other smart contract platforms
the smart contract platform d5
is likely overvalued and the defy on
bitcoin is likely
undervalued and it's merely because
people wrote it off
and here is one of the last things i'm
gonna leave you with and i got three
questions you're gonna ask me one to
finish up
in 1999 and 2000
every single idea that ended up being
successful on the internet was tried
streaming music
file sharing food delivery
subscription businesses all of it
put a dot com on the end raise tons of
money
launch your product cross your fingers
and hope you can ipo
take the cache and run before people
realized
it wasn't ready yet right the ecosystem
the technology the user experience
the customer adoption the psychological
understanding of what was happening the
smartphones
right all of this stuff was not in a
place
where those ideas time had come
fast forward 10 to 15 years to 2010
to 2015. food sharing
or i'm sorry uh uh ride sharing
food delivery streaming music file
sharing
all that stuff now is here
sometimes the ideas take a decade
to actually hit because you need
adoption
user experience you need psychological
understanding you need developers
infrastructure all that stuff my bet
with sovereign
is that just like if you had taken the
ideas from 1999 and 2000 and continued
to reinvest in them over and over and
over again for the next 15 years
you eventually invested in the most
valuable companies in the world
that if you go back and you look at 2009
10
11 and 12 you look at all those ideas
and you invest in them now most of them
are being we're we're targeting it being
built on top of bitcoin
and we start looking at them now they're
going to be some of the most valuable
products companies projects etc moving
forward
sovereign is building a fully
decentralized
vertically integrated financial system
financial platform
with what i believe and i think you
believe is going to be the next global
reserve currency
if it is the next global reserve
currency and sovereign continues to
build great technology
that has great user experience and does
all the things you need for product
market fit et cetera
it is likely that we will continue to
see
more and more migration of users some
from other smart contract platforms
some from bitcoin who just now realize
they can use their bitcoin
and some who literally come to use those
products and then happen to buy bitcoin
to
use within the system but if that occurs
my guess is
12 to 24 months from now we're talking
about sovereign as one of the largest d5
platforms in the world
i think that's likely i think it's very
likely
today with a billion dollars plus
managed by the system
top 25 d5 product
yeah i mean it's um somewhere in there i
mean
it really depends how you how you
measure it but um
like i actually don't think that sort of
tvl is the
right measure um i think you probably
rather want to be looking at
transactional activity okay
but you know yes it's definitely already
you know in the top tens
and growing probably more rapidly than
almost any other one
but also not only is it growing faster
i don't think it has the same glass
ceiling that the others do right
i think it i don't think that there's
that limit first of all the bitcoin
the pool of liquidity it accesses with
bitcoin is vastly greater
but beyond that like you know
sovereign has for the last year or so
mostly been building out basic
infrastructure
and users who are using server now have
started to notice a change that things
are starting to come much
much more quickly and the reason is a
lot of that basic infrastructure has
been built and so now it's getting built
out are the features which is why
it rapidly went from just another
protocol to the
most feature-rich protocol in d5 and so
you know all right but now what comes
next is what's crazy
because what comes next is things that
nobody has
there's a team there's at least one team
that i'm involved with
with which is working on providing a new
way of providing global mortgages
right there's a team working on on
crypto pensions
which could be provided to people who
have who would like to have
like more higher more highly assured
pensions
right so right now your pension is
assured by the government which we
already said like
legal assurances are not as good as
cryptographic insurances
so there's work around that
um soon there's a team which is almost
done working on
a way for you to um get zero interest
loans on your bitcoin
this is going to be huge right like
you've got bitcoin you can go to block
fight today
and you can pay in you know some kind of
interest rate take on the counterparty
risk of block fi
and pay you know some fairly expensive
rate
in order to borrow on against your
bitcoin so that you don't have to sell
your bitcoin
sovereign is going to have zero interest
zero counterparty risk
uh liquidity for you on your bitcoin
there's um
margin trading with bitcoin against like
for example ethereum which is about to
come there's a team working on perpetual
swaps the most popular protocol in
uh in d5 and they um are working with
people from the
working with the people who invented it
from from bitmix all this stuff
like the amount of stuff that is about
to come to sovereign
i don't know if it's going to be i think
you're going to start over the next few
weeks already seeing some of this stuff
but like the pipeline of stuff that
people are building for sovereign just
doesn't end
it's it's um i think it's
i think no one is ready for what's for
what's overnight
all right three questions that we're
gonna finish up sure first most
important book you've ever read
all right well given the conversation
we're having today i'm gonna suggest the
sovereign
individual that's a layup all right
second question uh sleep schedule our
friends that ate sleep
uh i've got a thermo-regulated bed i
turn it super cold i sleep like a baby
used to sleep five or six hours now i
sleep seven or eight
uh absolute game changer uh what is your
sleep schedule today and how has that
changed over the years
all [ __ ] up um i uh now that i'm
on america time what i tend to do is
wake up around 3 30 a.m or 4 a.m
work for a few hours then go back to
sleep so that i can
be in touch with people from like asia
and europe
and then
[Music]
do some more work and then sort of try
and leave evenings open
this is working okay but i wouldn't say
it's a lifestyle that that is highly
sustainable
um yeah sleep's a challenge um but
then again it always is uh in a book you
need to sleep come on let's go
get you nate sleep all right third
question aliens believer or non-believer
i think there's huh
all right let's talk about alien
intelligences for just a moment i think
they're here and we made them
and what do i mean by this i actually
think that
you can think of government as an alien
intelligence
you can think of corporations as an
alien intelligence you can think about
um the financial system as an alien
intelligence what do i mean by that
every single bee has a brain
right but it the the hive makes
collective decisions which often
are not even to the good of the
particular b they're detrimental to the
specific bees right
human beings have created these ways of
working like let's talk about a
government for a second
um a government has desires
it has motivations it has intentions
right
and it has an intelligence um
but that is not the intelligence of
any one of the single human beings that
is in the system right trump
was not deciding what the united states
would be doing and biden isn't deciding
right now
it's something else it's an alien
intelligence
and i don't think it's a particularly
friendly one
um so do aliens come from outer space
maybe
but i think the bigger thing that we're
not paying attention to
is that we in our collective action do
create
alien intelligence and very often this
alien intelligence is hostile to us
which is why coming back to our
conversation
why having better ways of decentralized
coordination
where anyone can also opt out is so
important
decentralization is obviously a better
system
all right you can ask me one question
what do you got for me
um what for you has been
the uh
yeah i i think i i'm really interested
what got you so
into this into bitcoin yeah freedom
but like where did that come from like
my whole life
uh i mean i was in the army right yes
which is exactly now i mean like my
point is like people like i was also in
the military
right typically the people who are most
interested in individual freedom don't
end up in the military it's not a great
place for individual freedom right
yes but at the same time i think that
they believe
in the ability to liberate
and they believe in some semblance of
ethics principles
uh and collective freedom
that drives individual freedom so you
can't have individual freedom if you
don't have collective freedom
right if you're in a communist country i
don't care what you say you don't have
individual freedom
you have to have democracy you have to
have capitalism you have to have these
kind of core principles in order to then
empower that individual freedom
i have a very unique um perspective on
the world
because military deployments
i've traveled a lot i understand
economics i want school for it
uh i've been at a number of technology
companies i've built companies i've done
a bunch of investing like i've done a
lot of
weird uncorrelated non-connected things
in my life
the single most important issue that we
all face
is that 50 plus percent of
the citizenry across the world is being
systematically
put into poverty yeah full stop yeah
that is what is happening
and the absolute biggest scam
is the monetary manipulation that goes
on
that drives the bottom 50 percent of
people
into poverty because they don't
understand
that the dollar is being devalued or
their local currencies being devalued
you will not educate them all it is
nearly impossible they don't care they
want to go to movies they want to go
[ __ ] eat they want to go hang out
with their friends whatever
i don't want to hear it i got 20 bucks
in my pocket i'm good
don't talk to me about this economic
stuff
the only way you can solve that problem
is through technology
in a peaceful protest of the system and
to get that asset
into the hands of as many people as you
possibly can
because it is the only salvation that
they have because they will not change
their behavior i so agree with you
like we've tried to solve human misery
and collective action problems using the
liberal arts way
for the last 3 000 years and had made no
progress the only thing
that has ever provided real human
progress is technology
i said this before people get very upset
when i say it but i stand by it
the adoption of bitcoin will bring more
positive impact to the world than all
philanthropic efforts combined 100
percent agree
for exactly the same reason it will
solve the one major problem
yeah which is the devaluing of the fiat
currency
puts billions of people
further and further into poverty misery
precarious positions when you fix the
money
you fix the world look we've had
technologies that have improved all
kinds of things
and finally we have a technology of
freedom
that is that is why i think we're living
in the most optimistic time
ever that's what i think too where can
we send people to find you on the
internet
um yeah twitter probably uh at ida
niagara
all right and what about sovereign
sovereign either the sovereign
so i've built it out with some other
people a website for sovereign which is
um sovereign s-o-v-r-y-n.app
dot s-o-v-r-y-n-app that's right or on
twitter um sovereign ptc
because that's the way you want your btc
to be
all right man thank you so much for
doing this we'll definitely do it again
in the future all right man
stay suffering